immer mehr Experten fragen nach Gründen
der deutlichen Übersterblichkeit und
auch bundestagsvize Wolfgang Kubicki
will ist jetzt wissen im Interview mit
der Welt fordert er jetzt eine Obduktion
und Überprüfung von Todesfällen nach der
corona-impfung kubiki bezieht sich dabei
auf eine Studie von Heidelberger
Pathologen mit Peter Schirrmacher der
herausgefunden hatte das war 30% aller
von ihm untersuchten Fälle die Impfung
die Todesursache gewesen sei darüber
sprechen wir jetzt
fordert Obduktionen muss ich die Politik
dieser Aufklärung stellen
die Aufklärung aller corona-maßnahmen
ist entscheidend es ist kann nicht dabei
bestehen geblieben werden jetzt zu sagen
wir sind irgendwie durchgekommen und und
jetzt wir sind noch gar nicht mal völlig
durchgekommen es gibt immer noch
Maßnahmen sondern wir müssen jetzt auch
sehen wie beginnen wir eine echte
Aufarbeitung und zwar eine die auch
damit beginnen zu sagen wo sind Fehler
gemacht worden und wie können wir
sicherstellen dass diese Fehler nicht
mehr passieren also Obduktionen sind für
Sie auch eine Maßnahme über die man
nachdenken sollte ich denke schon dass
das in ein Element ist das warum war der
übrigens einmal ganz am Anfang der Krise
wurde das übrigens auch schon gemacht da
gab es diesen Hamburger Arzt der das in
Einzelfällen machte also ich glaube
schon dass es letztlich ist wir müssen
wissen was dort passiert ist wir können
nicht bei diesem bei diesem Unwissen was
wir derzeit haben stehen bleiben
gleichzeitig läuft die Impfkampagne
einfach weiter schenken Sie dem jetzt
noch sehr viel Vertrauen in der jetzigen
Lage nein nach wie vor natürlich nicht
weil es kommen immer mehr Fremdheiten
ans Tageslicht wir wissen ja die erste
Impfung hat nicht funktioniert wir sind
jetzt bei der vierten Impfung in der
Zwischenzeit ist er damals geheißen
lieber nebenwirkungsfreies wird die
wärst so gut getestet es wird definitiv
keine im langfristigen Schäden geben
pustekuchen jetzt sind wir da wir haben
eine Übersterblichkeit im November
gehabt von 19% zum Vorjahr wir sehen das
immer mehr Menschen sich beklagen weil
sie irgendwelche Hautirritation haben
herzmuskelentzündungen Irritation
genereller Natur und dahin gehen muss
ich sagen hatten die Kritiker wohl
anscheinend alle recht und deswegen habe
ich sehr sehr wenig Vertrauen diesen
ungetesteten neuen Impfstoff ja findest
du dass die Regierungen
nachkommen sollte also im Prinzip finde
ich Aufklärung immer gut und es ist
extrem wichtig dass gerade nicht nur was
das Thema Sterblichkeit angeht sondern
auch generell was die Folgen von
Maßnahmen angeht wir ein
Untersuchungsausschuss im Bundestag
bekommen da gab es eine Abstimmung
bereits die ist leider abgeschmettert
worden ist interessant die FDP hatte im
Wahlkampf im letzten Jahr ja noch massiv
getrommelt und gesagt es muss dann auch
ein Untersuchungsausschuss in der
nächsten Legislaturperiode geben kaum
sind die Liberalen an der Macht war das
mit dem Untersuchungsausschuss dann doch
kein richtiges Thema mehr also wir haben
da eine Allianz von Politiker natürlich
auch gerade auf unionsseite auf SPD
Seite die gar keinen großes Interesse
haben ein Untersuchungsausschuss im
Bundestag einzusetzen aber er wäre
dringend dringend nötig beunruhigen dich
die Zahlen beunruhigen dich auch das was
gesagt wird dass auch Ärzte vermuten da
gibt es mehr Fälle da fällt uns etwas
auf es ist immer noch schwer
Zusammenhänge danach zu weisen und das
beunruhigt natürlich aber ich stell mir
auch immer wieder vor wie war denn die
Situation damals 2020 zu Beginn des
Jahres in der Mitte des Jahres am Ende
des Jahres und wenn wir ehrlich sind in
uns hereinhorchen dann haben wir die
meisten zumindest von uns ich sehe die
kritischen Blicke von Herrn Friedrich
doch eigentlich doch eigentlich danach
eine Impfung gibt und ich habe bis heute
vielleicht liegt daran weil es keine
oder mehr erkennbar keine Nebenwirkung
bisher bereitet hat aber bin eigentlich
sehr dankbar dass ich diese Impfung
bekommen habe wir wissen das war ein
Wettlauf mit mit der Zeit wir wissen
auch dass die Verfahren bei diesen
Impfstoffen die wir hatten völlig anders
waren als normal also auch viel kürzer
dass wir mehr oder weniger auch
Probanden möglicherweise gewesen sind
aber das war der Situation sicherlich
geschuldet sicherlich war falsch von
vielen Politikern zu sagen dass es alles
nebenwirkungsfrei das konnte zu dem
Zeitpunkt keiner wissen da ist jeder der
sich hat impfen lassen ins eigene Risiko
gegangen und deswegen ist es einfach
nicht so gesagt oder genau das ist auch
wieder ein Problem und das muss auch
wieder aufgearbeitet werden völlig
richtig ohne Frage
nichtsdestotrotz bin ich weiterhin froh
dass es so schnell im Stoff gegeben hat
und das sehr so schnell zur Verfügung
gestanden hat wir haben schon ein
bisschen kopfschüttelt ja also los also
wegen der Aufarbeitung ich meine Jens
Spahn ehemalige Gesundheitsminister hat
sich jetzt schon bisschen entschuldigt
und so ein Lauterbach hat ja auch gesagt
okay die Kita Stiftung waren eigentlich
defacto nicht notwendig die
kulateralschäden die Leben erleben wir
bis heute die Nachbeben werden wir auch
erleben weil die die Gesellschaft ist
gespalten wie noch nie zuvor und ich
glaube da bleibt dann solltest du nicht
bleiben wir brauchen auf jeden Fall auch
ein juristische Aufarbeitung weil wir
wurden wie gesagt Milliarden teilweise
verschwendet wir haben einen
wirtschaftlichen Schaden wir haben
Kollateralschäden innerhalb der Familie
Freundschaften sind kaputt gegangen und
da müssen wir aufarbeiten um auch wieder
zu heilen und Brücken zu bauen in ihrem
Thema da kommen wir auch gleich zu
bleiben wir einmal noch kurz bei den
Impfungen die Impfkampagne läuft ja
weiterhin Jan findest du es gut dass sie
weiterhin angesichts einer Informationen
die man jetzt gerade zusammen trägt
einfach so weiter läuft also mein
Eindruck war schon dass wir dass die
Verläufe die wir gesehen haben nach der
dem starte im Kampagne anders waren
milder waren als wir sie hatten ohne die
im und wir sehen ja auch wie panisch ein
Regime wie China jetzt reagiert da Max
sicherlich auch andere Gründe für GEMA
wir sehen ja schon dass die Impfung da
offenbar einen gewissen Schutz geboten
hat das mag nicht bei jedem gewesen sein
und es ist ganz bedauerlich dass es da
offenbar auch viele Menschen gibt die
jetzt extreme Nebenwirkungen haben und
mit Blick auf die Übersterblichkeit da
möglicherweise auch noch andere wirklich
dann tödliche Reaktion erfolgt sind dass
das eine aber damit Punkt den Herr
Friedrich gemacht hat und der ist auch
noch mal extrem wichtig ist die
Aufarbeitung auch für möglicherweise
neue Pandemie zu sagen was ist passiert
was haben wir vielleicht richtig gemacht
aber was ist vor allem extrem falsch
gelaufen und da muss man sagen nach
einem was wir jetzt wissen was wir auch
schon zu in pandemiezeiten wussten dass
der Umgang mit den Kindern eine
Katastrophe gewesen ist eine absolute
Katastrophe die Folgen sind jetzt
spürbar und ich glaube da muss man
vielen Politikern von der Spitze und
auch der damaligen Bundeskanzlerin
angefangen den massiven Vorwurf machen
viel zu wenig z.B auf Kinderärzte gehört
zu haben in dieser Pandemie viel viel zu
wenig und die ganzen Folgen die es gab
an negativen für die Kinder Kleinkinder
aber auch Schulkinder völlig außer Acht
gelassen zu haben diese schullockdowns
die wir gesehen haben waren nirgendwo so
schlimm wie in Deutschland und haben zu
dramatischen negativen Folgen geführt
und da wirklich muss aufgearbeitet
werden dass so etwas nie wieder passiert
pression Übergewicht soziale Kontakte
sind steigen wir gleich noch ganz tief
eine vor allem auch lückgewinde Sie dazu
auch noch mal ähm ihr Wort und ihre
Gedanken uns mitteilen ich will einmal
noch bei der Impfung bleiben jetzt unter
all diesen Bedingungen die wir jetzt
gerade sehen die Impfung immer noch
unter bedingter Zulassung haben sie
vertrauen überhaupt nicht also in die
Impfung gar nicht und wenn man sieht
dass ich auch inzwischen
hochrangige Politiker entschuldigen
tatsächlich in Alberta ist das passiert
da hat die Premierministerin sich für
das im Regime regelrecht entschuldigt
und auch die ganzen Maßnahmen die
gemacht wurden das ist etwas das würde
ich mir in Deutschland inzwischen auch
wünschen denn man hat ja eigentlich es
war eigentlich leicht zu sehen dass
einen Impfstoff der auch völlig neuartig
noch ist wo man gar nicht wissen kann
muss diese Feldstudien noch gar nicht
gibt dann hasst dich über dieses
teleskopierte Verfahren die Studien
praktisch parallel beschleunigt dass man
natürlich nicht über die Langzeitwirkung
weiß das ist doch eigentlich
offensichtlich und wie kann man sowas
überhaupt sagen dass das
nebenwirkungsfrei ist also da gibt es
viel härtere Testverfahren für
Impfstoffe für normale Impfstoffe und
trotzdem hat man das zu nicht nur
zugelassen sondern auch noch empfohlen
und dann auch noch schließen Kindern
empfohlen
leise beispielsweise läuft die
Impfpflicht auch noch in der Bundeswehr
wir hatten hier zweimal ein Gast sitzen
Soldaten die weiterhin verpflichtet sind
sich impfen zu lassen den finanzieller
[Gelächter]
Einbuße halten
nein also natürlich nicht das ist völlig
klar aber ich verstehe auch nicht warum
warum einige Politiker so krampfhaft
immer noch daran festhalten natürlich
werden die selbst auch sich verteidigen
wollen dass das das Richtige war damals
bloß die müssen doch erkennen dass das
so nicht weitergehen kann das wird ja
nur noch schlimmer das heißt man sieht
doch jetzt noch stärker erhöhte
Todesraten also man kann das direkt
schon jetzt in den Statistiken sehen und
dass sie immer noch nicht zurückrudern
ja die es hilft eigentlich nur die
Vollbremsung alles stoppen und dann
zurückrudern und sich Anfang erstmal
damit dem Thema ein intensiv zu
beschäftigen und dann sich zu
entschuldigen natürlich
auch immer so schwer
es fällt schwer weil ist das
Eingeständnis eines fehlersystem man
gemacht hat und Fehler zuzugeben das
bedeutet am Ende immer auch ein Stück
Glaubwürdigkeit zu verlieren es gibt
viele die sagen nein das würde die
Glaubwürdigkeit ja aber ein Politiker
der sich zwei drei mal entschuldigt für
Sachen die er falsch gemacht hat der hat
natürlich das den Makel Mensch weiß ich
als Wähler eigentlich ob der diesmal
richtig liegt möglicherweise liegt der
schon wieder versteht der wieder falsch
also das ist ja immer dann der Markt und
gerade in Krisen ist es glaube ich gut
auch Menschen an der Regierungsspitze zu
haben die sich nicht zu häufig in ihrem
Leben geirrt haben weil man dann davon
ausgehen kann dass sie die Entscheidung
die Sie treffen hoffentlich richtig
getroffen haben wir gesehen bei der
Bundeskanzlerin aber dass das in Sachen
Corona Politik in vielen Fällen nicht
richtig war was sie gemacht hat und man
ein Eindruck ist auch in der
Nachbetrachtung wir haben es mit einer
sich selbst beschleunigen denn ähm ja
Entwicklung in der Politik gehabt also
wenn man auch noch mal denkt an das
Thema Bundes Lockdown was wir plötzlich
hatten also wir gehen in 22 22 in ein
Lockdown bis Sommer
dann kam ein Lockdown light im Herbst
dann wurde die Geschäfte auch noch
geschlossen dann war es ein größerer
Lockdown und dann gab es ja noch mal die
Idee mit dem sogenannten osterarrest
oder osterruhr wie immer und ein Bundes
Lockdown über die Osterwochen noch mal
verschärft das ganze Land für zehn Tage
komplett stillzulegen also in welcher
Welt haben wir uns eigentlich Befunden
im Nachhinein Entschuldigung und ein
zurückrudern aber nur für dieses Oster
diese sogenannte osterruhe da wurde uns
ja auch verkauft wir müssen alle jetzt
in Ruhe zu Hause bleiben also eigentlich
haben wir das war wirklich ein
osterreste mir wurde nämlich eigentlich
gezwungen hätten gezwungen werden zu
Hause zu bleiben so und da gab es
eigentlich eher so etwas wie noch
schneller noch weiter noch höher ähm in
der Politik vorangetrieben auch von der
Bundeskanzlerin die sich ein Berater
starb zurechtgelegt hatte der auch immer
nur in eine Richtung marschierte und
andere Stimmen wurden nicht gehört so
und wenn ich mich in so einer Welle und
so einer sage ich mal Panik ja so ein
Modus befinde dann geht's natürlich
immer nur
schneller voran ganz genau das ist ein
Problem in ihrem Zimmer gelandet ihnen
ist nämlich eine Entschuldigung nicht
genug es muss mehr passieren es muss
wirklich aufarbeitet werden wenn mir
einige Sachen bereits hier in dieser
Sendung angesprochen jetzt heißt es
Kinder für die Kinder ja Schul- und
Kitas hätten nie geschlossen werden
müssen sollen davon haben die Kinder
jetzt heute gar nichts mehr ist es Ihre
Zeit es ist Ihre Kamera es geht jetzt um
die Aufarbeitung der vergangenen drei
Jahre